le département de la réunion aux côtés
des réunionnais vous êtes de la
recherche d'un assistant maternel d'une
application a été mise en place afin de
faciliter vos recherches
grâce à celle ci vous trouverez un
assistant maternel proche de chez vous
vous pouvez accéder à l'application sur
votre smartphone en téléchargeant
enfants confiance via l'app store l'app
store via le site du département
rubrique enfance trouvait nessma comment
l'utiliser
l'utilisation de l'application est
simple il suffit d'entrer le numéro le
nom de votre rue ainsi que votre code
postal
vous trouverez les assistants maternels
et les maisons d'assistants maternels
proche de votre domicile
l'application vous permet aussi d'avoir
les informations générales le cadre
d'accueil mais également les
disponibilités de l'assistant maternel
ainsi plus besoin de vous dépasser ou de
faire beaucoup de recherches
vous pouvez en quelques clics trouver un
assistant maternel pour votre enfant